so one you know I don't know how many of
you know the story but this started to
honor my son right I lost my son to
medical malpractice he taught me so much
about happiness and instead of being
motivated by the negative which could be
vengeance against the surgeon or the
hospital I was motivated by the positive
of saying okay this wonderful soul came
into my life he taught me so so much to
honor him I'm gonna teach 10 million
people what he taught me if I can get 10
million people to remember him then it
doesn't bring him back but it makes the
world a better place it's a good way
instead of saying a life for a life I
said to myself I'd his life is not worth
one life it's worth 10 million lives
right and those 10 million lives need to
be given not taken right I was amazing
the minute I decided to do that the
whole universe conspired like the whole
world is helping right now being
motivated by that positive then got me
to the point where I've suddenly
realized that if if 10 million is
possible why is a billion not possible
if a billion happens we change the world
yes right now we're in the heart of
technology everyone in this room knows
that the billion is not a big number on
the internet it's not everything I've
ever done at Google Oz and billions
right imagine if we have a billion
people that tell the world what our
parents were supposed to teach us our
parents tried to teach us to be nice to
be polite to be courteous to be generous
to be kind if you just change yourself
just yourself hmm and there are there
are a billion of us out there you know
what will happen we will dilute the
entire Internet in two years mm-hmm
if you follow a proper doubling function
so I'm using Moore's Law here if we move
from where we are today on 1 billion
happy which is we don't know the exact
numbers but the reach of the videos have
been now in the hundreds of millions we
we're estimating
somewhere around 37 million actually
took action right if we keep doubling
every year we get to a billion happy in
five years and the trick is if we double
one more time remember the exponential
function it's two billion happy on year
six now add 2 billion happy we have the
majority of the internet right it's it's
not it's a crazy task but you know what
and I will say and you know think of me
as crazy but I will tell you if we don't
do it we're toast we're toast
totally toast right we're teaching a
much smarter being to behave as horrible
as we are very bad idea it's a very bad
idea and the behavior change comes from
within absolutely that's the whole game
huh